[Music]
so really big part of korean meals is
the act of eating together as a family
in fact the korean word for family is
shikku which literally means a group
that eats together
so through this meal i thought i would
share some of that korean culture with
my friends even though we can't be in
the same place right now
all right
all right welcome to day one of cooking
with your boy so to start things off i
thought we would do the appetizers first
now what is the korean equivalent of an
appetizer
side dishes or panchan now i'm so
positive that none of my friends have
had any of these side dishes before and
i'm hoping to just
show them that there's more out there
than you know korean barbecue
or kimchi all right so let's get started
right now i'm going to embody my inner
korean mom
every korean mom spirit out there just
give me strength and we're gonna do that
with an og korean mom apron country cats
baby
let's get it all right so the first side
dish we're gonna do is the radish salad
and because i don't feel like cutting
all the slices of radish
here's a tip for you go into your korean
mother's kitchen and look for these
this is um it's a thing all right
[Music]
honestly i'm not too concerned i feel
like these are just side dishes
so i don't think it'd be that hard
all right radish salad is complete look
at this masterpiece
i told y'all i told you all the apron is
where it's at all right so one down
three to go
and it only took me two hours
jesus christ
[Music]
alright so since i am making kimchi i'm
gonna give a call to the person who
makes the best kimchi in the world
mama king
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
i'm gonna try my best to save it but
worst case scenario i'm gonna tell them
that this is how it's supposed to taste
all right here it is i really don't
think they'll notice
please don't notice all right recipe
number three it is stir-fried anchovies
i saved this one towards the end because
i thought it was gonna be hard but i
really feel like this might be the
easiest one so far
[Music]
oh sh stuff the whole thing in by
accident okay
[Music]
i'm gonna go in with the sauce now
[Music]
all right honestly this is looking
pretty good i'm to give it a taste real
quick
yo this is my best one yet so far i
think
[Music]
fire that's right
get at me all right i'm on my last one
the brace black beans it's nine o'clock
let's just get this over with
all right i think these beans are about
done let's give it a check
oh that is beautiful all right here it
is
i'm gonna hit it with the sesame seeds
like this oh sesame bay
all right so end of day one i am
absolutely exhausted
i really thought this was gonna be easy
day i just spent eight hours making four
freaking side dishes that's it for me
i'll see you guys tomorrow
welcome back it is day two today we're
gonna be focusing on the main dish
as well as a soup korean people love
soup today i got some uh
bulgogi so yeah i'm gonna be making
bulgogi
as well as kimchi which is basically
kimchi stew
you already know we can't cook without
our country cat's apron
i look good okay let's get to cooking
oh sh
oh my god probably gonna cut that out
[Music]
okay
all right so i think this is good we're
now going to move on to the kimchi stew
and lucky for my friends i will be
sacrificing the last of my mom's kimchi
in order to feed my friends
all right we got the kimchi still
cooking right now oh
you see that let me just give this a
taste real quick
[Music]
all right so the kimchi stew is cooking
we got our bulgogi out of the fridge
and now who better to call than my very
own grandma
here we go i really hope she answers
grandma hi baby let me tell you what i'm
doing real quick so
basically i'm frozen wait let me get on
my lp
okay is it better it got significantly
worse
this is my grandma who doesn't know how
to use technology but
i don't know what happened she just hung
off
how have you been feeling during um
these weird times
i'm taking it day by day and i'm used to
this time to
realize who i you forget
how much love i'm surrounded by yeah you
are loved
and i hope that we all can get through
this together
knowing that the only thing we need is
love and i love you
thanks i love you too give yourself a
break just be yourself you're more than
enough
thanks grandma of course any time baby
all right end of day two i'm not as
excited as i was when i first started
but tomorrow's the last day so i just
want to finish it up all right
calling your night adios
[Music]
our final day today we're doing dessert
the dessert that i picked today is
called
shikke which is basically rice punch now
this is definitely not the hardest thing
that we've made all week but
it is definitely the most time intensive
so yeah
let's get to it
[Music]
now this has to sit for a few hours so
i'm going to put a little wrap over it
leave it alone and then come back when
it's ready all right so while i'm
waiting on that i'm also going to make
some rice because it wouldn't be rice
punch without any
so i'm going to go ahead and wash this
and then i'm going to use my trusty good
old
rice cooker my best friend don't tell
andrew
[Music]
all right now we got our mixture and we
got our rice we're gonna take our bowl
and very carefully pour the mixture into
the rice
now i'm going to take this rice and put
it back in the rice cooker let it
ferment for about four hours
and then i'll come back and check it
again after that
all right so i'm going to open this up
and what we're looking for here is for a
few grains of rice that floated to the
top
if there are none floating that's an
issue because it's already 10 o'clock
and i want to do this anymore so
please please please please
oh snap yo this is a pool
oh my goodness my hard work is finally
paid off
all right so i transferred the punch to
a big pot and now i'm bringing up to a
boil
and in the meantime i might as well just
call this guy
yo what are you up to i am killing man i
was about to play xbox
what are you doing did i tell you what
i've been doing this week i'm sleeping
no okay i don't know
that's your only guest sleeping
[Music]
i appreciate that the fact that you're
spreading that like joy
man when um when's dinner
um so i'm thinking i'm gonna drop it off
to you guys tomorrow
oh um you know i'm in phoenix right
what i'm in phoenix
i'm not gonna ship it how am i supposed
to ship this
i guess your love and your joy doesn't
spread to one state over
so it's cool this is not my fault all
right you need to talk to fedex about
this issue all right because it's not my
fault
bro and like i think they're really
gonna like it like i think this is gonna
go really well
i think they're gonna appreciate the
effort though man like i think the home
cooked meal is less about
it being perfect or good and it's more
about the love that you put in the meal
all right since i got you on the line i
might as well just try it one more time
i feel like
it should be okay by now
i think that's it i think that's it
[Music]
teamwork baby teamwork
so day three is complete i'm finally
done with this challenge
i'm so done with this challenge the big
dinner is finally tomorrow
i'm a little worried but you know i
tried my best so
what else can i say i'll see you all
tomorrow
i was upstairs taking a nice little nap
and uh this guy sean just texted me to
go check
my front porch you know how sean is
weird all right let's see what this guy
got going on
yo this dude is weird man is that what
he wants me to get
what is this i've seen this movie before
there's probably a bomb in here
look at the packaging with my name on it
this is definitely rice in a big bowl of
water
okay sean did he make this it's in
tupperware
his mom came to visit this looks really
good oh
shiny boy did such a good job
oh look this little note look dinner is
at 7 p.m
shawn's planning something i don't know
what's going on we'll find out at 7 00
p.m
wait what time is it
[Music]
i know this quarantine has been really
tough and difficult for everyone so
i spent an entire week cooking
traditional korean food
and so that explains why you guys have a
whole spread right now except for andrew
i'm sorry andrew
but i hope it don't taste good
it's gonna be real real which one i'm
joking i love you all i love you all all
you guys are the best
i'll see you in late real soon i'll be
back
are you guys eating with a fork like
you're eating with a fork
i mean what a fork this is actually kind
of nice sharing
a meal it feels like you guys are like
here all right guys let's do it cheers
to
staying strong during this quarantine
all right yes
cheers hey wait wait wait wait everybody
keep it up keep it up
cheers to sean for hooking us up with
this great meal
and uh thanks a lot buddy yeah cheers
all right guys i'll see you later
all right this was definitely one of the
most stressful weeks
i've had in a very long time especially
during those moments where i would face
a lot of doubt
i think calling my mom andrew and joyce
really helped a lot because
it really felt like they were in the
kitchen with me encouraging me to just
keep pushing forward and not give up
and that was the whole point of this
meal really was to remind the people
closest to me that we're gonna get
through this together
i'm not crying my voice just gone
[Music]